Jason talking about Gary and his candy
oh my god all boys there's up in some
craziness in the office with Gary and
candy since Halloween so we came back
this week and some of the people in the
back of the office had put out a
cardboard box filled with leftover
Halloween candy okay
and Gary discovered it we started
watching him at least three times in one
hour on this one day he went up he
double fisted kid he walked out with two
hands
he had an empty coffee cup and he filled
it that was the first where people upset
that he was taking all of the candy it
was like a bad you know show up fairly
you didn't need to worry about it cuz it
hey if you wanted a Hershey kiss you go
back to you get a Hershey kiss and walk
away but then once the cops start
getting filled and double 15 it's like
damn if you want and you guys ran a
surveillance on him you took pictures we
chose we took pictures but the craziest
thing was the next day he goes there and
and one of the women that sits there
says you know there's no more chocolate
I think she was trying to throw him off
she's no more chocolate in there guys
you watch I will find some and he rooted
around in that box like a bear found
chocolate and he go home he turned
around cuz you see all the good shits on
the bottom you got to turn this [ __ ]
upside down I turn the Box on the side
and you take you taking all the candy
that the staff does plenty of candy left
for everyone not really that the guy
who's doing is out weighs 150 pounds but
he's sharing his charge yeah yeah I'm
not so powered by the way Hawking
everybody that's nothing I saw Gary
eating chocolate a few days ago he was
just scoff like a squirrel with nuts
just putting it away striking his cheeks
like a pig and squirrel a pig I said
Gary go Jesus Christ you really do love
this kit like this not a bit right guy
goes I swear he goes this is nothing at
home he goes when I really go on a
chocolate craze I buy a tub of chocolate
frosting and I need it to rip the Cana
might be time for an intervention but
control Gary take a container of
frosting with a spoon really that's a
fitting do you feel badly about yourself
out on this chocolate oh yeah you do and
you
I you were at my house you don't eat
vegetables do you I don't I never show
is amazing I have a salad every Tuesday